[Dave] So for question 3, the question is which of the following sequences
of statements leaves the value the variable x refers to
the same as it was before running the statements?
You should assume that before the code runs,
both a and x refer to integer values.
We don't know what they are. They could be any integer.
And the question is after the code runs, does x have the same value it had
before that code ran?
So here are the choices.
There are 5 different sequences of statements,
and you should check the box for each sequence where x
has the same value after executing those statements
as it did at the beginning, no matter what value x had at the beginning
as long as it was some number.